a warning her report contains images of
the child victims of Yemen's war right
from the start
weak with hunger after a lifetime of war
Mohammed Ibrahim is seen at a hospital
in her Dada during a lull in the
fighting for this port city that the
United Nations Special Envoy for Yemen
says must hold ahead of a plan to resume
peace talks in Sweden in the coming
weeks this is an opportunity which has
long been awaited by the people of Yemen
it is an opportunity which this council
has long asked of the parties I think
we're almost there
I don't know if we will make it I don't
know what the odds are we need to focus
to make sure that nothing disrupts the
path to that meeting Martin Griffith
updated the United Nations Security
Council about his efforts to end the war
between rebel Houthis and a saudi-led
coalition he also spoke exclusively to
Sky News about a belief that peace is
possible but warned of dire consequences
otherwise and if Furman takes hold in
Yemen if it does and we even still hope
it doesn't then the the the the enormity
of the humanitarian task to try and keep
people alive is mind-boggling Britain is
playing a part
promising to bring a draft resolution to
the UN on Monday to help ease the
suffering we do believe there is a
window of opportunity to tackle this
man-made crisis in Yemen I just want to
emphasize the man-made bit what what men
have created men can result in
rebel-held Haddad er they wait and hope
that words about peace become a reality
on the ground coalition airstrikes hit
the port on Monday threatening the most
important lifeline for food and fuel to
millions of people the head of the
united nations food agency visited the
area this week we need to protect this
port at all costs make sure certain that
it can function at the highest capacity
because if we don't
people are gonna die pro-government
forces backed by the coalition have
halted an all-out offensive on the city
for now but there are still bursts of
violence babies like these should be the
future of Yemen hope remains for this
tiny girl but eight month old Muhammad
Hassan has since died a reminder of the
individual tragedies each day without
peace brings Deborah Haines Sky News